i've we've done a video with each of you
now in like a hot tub like a bath so i
just got now
taste set yeah yeah oh yeah that video
got so many complaints because of the
whole breakfast ordeal
i got some [ __ ] for that really yeah i
got so many comments
so uh there was um we stayed i found
this thing on booking.com that was like
a five-star
um hotel it was just a townhouse in
kyoto
and uh yeah it was all right it was
would you say it's five stars lovely
this is five stars right and you come in
this living room and there's a tv
that's like 12 inches on a shelf and
there's nothing in this living room
it's literally nothing the record plan
there was a record player which is
pretty cool oh nice
and it had like a bunch of vinyl you
have to bring your own final player no
they had their they had vinyls
and that was cool but there was it was
just a living room with nothing in it
yeah absolutely no one bean bag one one
bean bag
but it had two bedrooms it had two
bedrooms right so crisco had a beanbag
chris got the deluxe
king triple comfort bed and i had to
sleep on the the floor
yeah [ __ ] uh what's it called three
times
yeah so it came out the front of this
kyoto townhouse and i looked up and it
was like this old woman just peering
over the edge like
and i was like [ __ ] what's she doing it
was like resident evil really
yeah and she's like looking at me yeah
and then i went back in the house
there's a woman so how much was it 500 a
day
i don't know 500 bucks a day oh damn no
no no
it wasn't like that's pretty [ __ ]
expensive 300
yeah it's about 280 dollars a day yeah
and it came with a free breakfast
you didn't have a say it just turned up
well the thing is i noticed that ryokans
are like ridiculously expensive but most
that cost
is just the breakfast you
i would say if this didn't come with the
food it'd probably be 200 bucks like the
food but
it came at like 8 a.m it's a great
breakfast
this is where the controversy what are
controversy we've got there's a few
comments like how dare you
yeah where this breakfast just gets
delivered to you eh outside and you you
open it up and it's just like 10 kind of
radish
just radish and like tofu and i'm not
being funny at 8 a.m
and i think we were hungover one day
we're just like i was like nah nah i'm
making this yeah ordered a mcdonald's
town
audacity yeah terrible
so what was the controversy then well
they were like how dare you waste the
food but i it was probably
was it one of the worst ones you've ever
seen it was pretty awful there wasn't
anything in there that i got excited
about put it that way yeah
it was pretty bad and then there was a
whole lot i got like my friend was like
they were like how dare you waste it i'm
like no i'm a customer i'm not wasting
it i
i don't get a say in whether it turns up
i didn't ask for it yeah yeah
yeah but do you feel bad because like i
it's
that i must not be the only person doing
it no you're not but like there's just
something about saying in japanese
ryokan where like i feel bad if i
don't eat the breakfast because
someone's specifically prepared
and like the thing is i don't want the
japanese breakfast if i had a choice
like i wouldn't
get it most of the time because i
remember the one time that we stayed in
ryokan and we had a
quite a bit of a heavy night and then
joey was [ __ ] hung over the next day
i couldn't see you and maki waiting
downstairs and i just felt so bad
because this like
old lady had obviously prepared this
like [ __ ] five course meal or
something
joey [ __ ] waddles in an hour late
takes one look at the breakfast takes
one bite of the fish and you're just
like
nope i can't do it no i can't do it guys
some days
i tried i tried so hard i was like only
like two things but like
if i eat anymore it's going back onto
the plate
it's really heavy as well i have that
multi-culture right like don't waste it
yeah yeah i i you know i always try my
best to eat what i can
yeah but some days i'm just like i
really just don't want breakfast and
also if i eat this i'm just gonna feel
like [ __ ]
so at the end of the day i've paid for
this yeah and i don't have to eat it i'm
a big boy i could i could decide not to
eat it because right it's like
rice like a [ __ ] ton of miso soup fish
a bunch of other [ __ ] at the time i
could do the miso soup because that's
like nice
miso soup and like tofu that's nice it's
like nice in the stomach so like i can
eat that all night
yeah fish maybe fish is dependent yeah
yeah
because like i don't eat breakfast a lot
normally yeah so
like a japanese breakfast it's like a
five course meal or something like that
and this is more than i have for lunch
let alone a [ __ ] breakfast yeah like
it's like it's like a breakfast you give
to someone who hasn't eaten in three
days you know
it's but at the same time a king even
isn't that hungry when he wakes up first
thing in the morning
i don't [ __ ] know even the kids like
chill the [ __ ] out from
henry you're [ __ ] morbidly obese
that's how you start your day yeah it's
ridiculous and you know
at the end of the day if you're a
customer i'm like you know what i'd only
do this
i don't want to oh yeah i mean you know
if you paid for it then it's your choice
right
you know i mean yeah it's not like i i
called them up like bring the breakfast
it gets here it's [ __ ] i don't want it
yeah it's like it's coming no matter
what
they're making it regardless and yeah
yeah because like with my plate most
places like breakfast is optional but
with it with a ryokan it's just part of
the package and you have no choice to
not have
all of the times i can hear
i could eat a lot but these things are
massive like if you're
like you know a smaller person who
doesn't eat much there's no way you
could finish it that's why i'm always
like surprised like with the amount of
food that arrives right and i'm like
how does like an 80 year old japanese
woman get up in the morning and eat
all of that i know right like hell yeah
one bite of everything
yeah leave it yeah i mean it's great the
first experience because you're like man
this looks [ __ ] amazing
it's like an instagram meal you take a
picture looks amazing posted and then
you're like
[ __ ] i've got to actually eat this now
[ __ ] i didn't think about that
it's just not sass i mean coming from
the uk we have like a big plate of
everything
yeah it's like i miss british fry ups
more than like anything about the uk
yeah i can't even do those either
because it's like i'm just i don't wake
up in the morning and feel hungry
it's more of a lunch thing yeah